a brand new month is approaching and
that means it's the perfect time
to let go you can play the 30-day
minimalism game and also download
our free printable 30-day minimalism
game calendar
over at theminimalists.com
how do you define tranquility
present calm content relaxed sure
yeah sure depends on what you mean by
tranquility as i
alluded to earlier the truth is found in
the essence not the abstraction
so these definitions they're only
approximations
we have only the english language and
it's 220 000
words to work with it can only summarize
the truth in a way so
how do you define tranquility what ideas
do you have
for how to achieve what i view as a
temporary state of being
and why that is important so is
tranquility
temporary yes but isn't everything
yeah it's interesting i look at
tranquility as
like peace being a synonym for it yes i
do too but tranquility comes with a
different
sense of because peace it feels
no emotion i feel like but tranquility
has like
it's not a high dose but it's like a
little tinch
tinch is that a pro is that an actual
measurement
it's a new measurement uh a tinge
of uh of
happiness yeah which
goes back to the point of tranquility is
absolutely ephemeral
right and it all is though right so so
peace is ephemeral tranquility
is what else they say present i mean the
present moment
is ephemeral and simultaneously eternal
and so we we have
we think of time in a linear fashion and
it makes sense that we do think of it
that way
but every moment is eternal and it's
hard for us to
you know in our 4d world right where we
have three dimensions plus time
it's hard for us to even conceive what
that
is we understand there are other
dimensions we understand that only
intellectually
if you were a 2d creature you wouldn't
understand the third
dimension either right right there's a
whole
carl sagan talk about this and in fact
if you could find that
sean might be worth putting in the show
notes carl sagan talking uh
he he gives like a a whole displ this
video display of like
why we can't really understand the
additional dimensions that are out there
it's like a 2d stick figure trying to
understand
what a third dimension is yeah and he
shows how absurd
that that really is yeah it's funny
anything i've ever seen on a like a
fourth dimension
it is absurd yeah it's yeah it's it's
pretty absurd
anyway because we lack that
understanding yeah
getting back to tranquility how do you
define tranquility i don't
think the definitions are going to be
important
for you here because tranquility we can
talk about what tranquility isn't
and that that can help us approximate it
yeah tranquility isn't conflict
right we've determined that i think you
and i agree that yeah that
conflict tranquility isn't suffering
tranquility is not disruption
tranquility is not what it's not elation
it's not good depression it's yeah
it's not um any extreme emotion it's not
pleasure
right either and i think too often we
confuse pleasure like
oh i feel in fact we we have drugs
called
tranquilizers you want real tranquility
and we mistake tranquilizing ourselves
for tranquility
we tranquilize ourselves every day with
pleasure
yeah i think uh
uh to to put a definition
i don't know tr tranquility to me means
not having any extreme emotions so
that's why i said you know peace you
know maybe is a synonym with tranquility
but i think like steven's asking this
because when we have these conversations
it's hard to um
keep up it's hard for me to keep up
first off um but it's hard to keep up
with
the conversation when
you you don't know what they're talking
i mean if we're talking about the word
tranquility
stephen has a very valid question of
like what do you mean when you say
tranquility right so that's why he's
looking for because he wants to follow
along with the conversation yeah
and so like i said the best way i can
approximate it is to say what it isn't
is to sort of do the chalk outline
around it right
now i i like what you said about being
uh what did you say about the emotion
thing it's absent of
extreme emotion and that's what
tranquilizers do
right so i think that's what
tranquilizers do i think tranquility
is absence of the effect of emotion
yeah and totally so the emotions can
still you can
experience anger it's like anxiety right
you can either say i'm an anxious person
or
anxiousness has arisen within me i
it's not that i am anxious it's that i'm
feeling
anxious in the moment and and if i can
divorce myself
from that not in a prescriptive sort of
way
but by understanding that anxiety will
arrive even in moments of tranquility
anxiety will arrive
the tranquil person is not affected
by that it's just like um a river
right when when the river keeps going
it'll be parts that
the river isn't worried about you know
where it's headed mm-hmm am i headed to
the ocean or the lake
does not have a frontal lobe right right
but we're talking about the state of no
mind right right exactly
meditativeness yes it is oh
yeah you are yeah you're getting
somewhere with this this is good and so
the the existence in and of itself we
are
constantly getting in the way of our own
existence yeah it's
really it makes me think about um
sam harris and the waking up app that
we're doing
mariah and i and how he
is just constantly every single
meditation
he's he's encouraged you encouraging you
to do two things
and the one is i've talked about uh on
one of our podcasts before about
starting again
and um i think if we can
start again when we have these very
sharp emotions
i think that can help us be more uh
tranquil
um but then the other thing he talks
about is
basically accepting all of the
disruptions that happen in our mind
but taking a step back and observing
the emotions which can lead us and help
us to get closer to being like a river
or to being like a rose
and um yeah and the beauty behind that
is if you can like master that which
i don't think that's a goal that's not
my goal but i could see where becoming
you know a master at that is you could
almost have this out-of-body experience
where you're kind of just observing
what's happening rather than
allowing it to control you essentially
people often describe
the out-of-body experience jordan i
don't know if you've experienced that
yet with the rock climbing you've been
doing but
it's uh i certainly experienced it with
writing i'm sure you've experienced it
with snowboarding
that's another way to describe the
meditativeness or the flow state or the
the no mind is the uh out of body
experience
because it doesn't require the the
cerebration
that um the turmoil
requires right and so when i talk about
being
less affected or unaffected by the
emotions that arise it doesn't mean that
they
don't arise they will still arise maybe
with different frequency once we better
understand
them but yes anxiety will still
arise but that doesn't mean i am anxious
it means i feel anxious and i can choose
not to cling
to it i'm really good at clinging to
anxiety
it doesn't serve me very well i'm just
very good at clinging in general you
have a clinging contest
[Laughter]
ready go